[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi everyone, and welcome to this
week's Google Developers
Live for the Google Drive SDK.
I'm Steve Bazyl.
Today I want to talk about a
new feature that is rolling
out for the Drive SDK that is
particularly of interest to
people who are writing
JavaScript client side
applications.
And this is improved
CORS Support.
The Drive SDK has had CORS
Support for most of the API
for a while now.
Certainly things like using
the RESTful API, and even
downloading resources has
been working fine.
But one piece has
been missing.
And that's support
for uploads.
And of course, since we want
to encourage you to store
files in Drive, that's a
very important part.
But starting just actually the
past couple of days, and still
rolling out, is CORS Support
for uploads.
And I want to show you
how that works.
And then take a look
at the code.
I built a little sample
up last night just
to show this off.
And it's really simple.
It's got a Google+ sign-in
button and we'll do a little
drag and drop to upload
some files.
So I want to switch
over to that.
And you can see here we just
have a sign-in button.
I'm going to sign in
really quick here.
You may not be able to see the
whole approval screen, but
it's just standard
Google+ sign in.
And then we have a nice
little drop zone.
So I'm going to just drag--
I have a couple of files
here, some PNG.
We'll drag that on, and then we
can see here that we have
the metadata from that file.
You can see that
it was created.
And if I go into Drive,
you see I have
this untitled document.
And we'll talk about
why we don't have a
title in just a moment.
But I want to switch over
to the code and
show what this is.
So you can see here the
page is very simple.
We have just a Google+ sign-in
button, our drop zone, and
actually this upload button
isn't even used anymore.
And of course, just an
area for results.
And then the rest of the
script is our code.
One thing you'll notice is the
only external script that I'm
loading here is the +1 button.
And that's really just out of
expediency because the plus
sign-in button is just a really
easy way to add OAuth
support to an application.
But if I didn't want to have
any dependencies, we can
certainly just implement that
function ourselves.
It's quite easy to do.
The rest of the code
is pretty simple.
We'll just start with just
the drag and drop.
We add some drag overs
and drop targets.
Handle the file selection.
And then we have this
media uploader.
This is just a small helper
class that I wrote to show how
to do this.
And we're going to do a simple
upload and show the results.
So pretty straightforward in
terms of just how the app
itself works.
Of course, the interesting part
is what happens in that
media uploader function itself
and the upload simple.
And before I show that, the
reason why this is so
important really comes
down two things.
So one, there's just a lot of
people out there who just
really prefer to write
vanilla JavaScript.
And they don't want to have
too many dependencies on
libraries, particularly the
Google APIs, which they have
their own script loader, it does
some dynamic loading to
actually get the client.
It can make testing a little
bit more difficult when you
have those kind of runtime
dependencies for
loading your scripts.
The other issue is when you're
doing things like a Chrome
packaged app, you have very
strict content security
policy, which actually prevents
you from including
external resources.
All the scripts need to be
packaged as part of the
application itself, which makes
using things like the
Google API client problematic.
There are ways around it in
terms of sandboxing content
and then using a post message to
communicate in between your
application and the
sandboxed frames.
But that's a lot of overhead
that you have to go through,
both from development and also
just in terms of how your app
functions and how easy
it is to debug.
It's just a lot of work.
So the nice thing of having CORS
Support for upload now is
if you are building something
like a Chrome packaged app,
you can use vanilla
JavaScript.
You can use the APIs that are
built in and fully supported
in that environment to work
with the Drive API.
So let's actually take a look
at this upload simple.
Let me just scroll up here.
You have a couple different
implementations of upload that
we'll talk about.
But this first one is pretty
straighforward.
What we're is we're using the
file APIs that are now part of
most modern browsers.
And we use that to read the file
that we dragged on there.
We just read it as
an array buffer.
So it could be binary content.
It really doesn't make
a difference.
And then to upload it, we just
use XML HTTP request.
It's a post to the Drive
upload endpoint.
It's a little bit different
than the normal RESTful
endpoint, which is
/drive/v2/files.
In this case, we just prefix
that with /upload.
Tell it that we're
doing media.
Media just indicates that we're
just posting the raw
file itself.
We're not giving it
any metadata.
And we're not specifying
titles or anything.
It's just here's the
bytes for the file.
And of course, set the content
type appropriately.
But other than that this
is vanilla JavaScript.
Again, no external libraries.
Just using the features that are
built into the browser in
order to do this.
And we saw on the demo that
that worked fine.
Of course, the problem with
media is you don't really get
to specify that much control
over how the file is
represented in Drive.
You certainly could, once the
upload is complete, take the
ID of that file and update
the metadata.
It's not quite as efficient as
just giving us the metadata
and the file up front.
And to do that, we have a
different upload protocol
called multipart.
And we'll actually just do
a quick demo of that.
I'm going to scroll
over to here.
I'll say upload multipart.
I'm going reload this page.
I did set my approval prompt to
[? force, ?] which is why
this button keeps showing up.
But normally, you would just get
signed in automatically.
And then this time let's
drag a PDF over.
So again, it works.
But you notice this
time, we actually
have the correct title.
You can see it here in the
metadata returned.
And if we switch over to Drive,
we see we actually have
the correct title
here as well.
So let's switch back over to the
implementation for that.
So again, we have this upload
multipart method, which is a
little bit different than
our upload simple.
And here we have to do
a little bit of work.
We have to actually be able to
assemble the multipart body.
So for those who are familiar
with doing multipart uploads,
this is going to be familiar.
If you're not, don't
worry too much.
It's actually not
that difficult.
But basically, we just create
a boundary to indicate the
different parts.
We create some metadata.
In this case, the file API in
the browser actually gives us
access to the title and the MIME
type that the operating
system, or the browser,
detects.
And we use that to populate the
metadata that we give to
the Drive API.
In this case, we really only
care about those two fields,
title and MIME type.
And then again, just like
before, we read the file.
Except this time, rather than
just posting the raw bytes of
the file, we're actually
going to build up
this multipart body.
And the nice thing is, if you
looked at the QuickStart that
we've had in our Docs
for JavaScript, this
code may look familiar.
In fact, we've had, using the
Java API client and some
tricks it uses with iFrame
proxies, you actually have
been able to do uploads
from JavaScript.
But again, it's been subject to
some restrictions in terms
of requiring our script, not
quite being incompatible with
packaged app CSP.
But the code for building the
multipart is actually already
in that QuickStart.
And so I took that and modified
it a little bit just
to make it a little bit cleaner
and take advantage of
some of the features that we can
now do by exploiting APIs
in modern browsers.
Specifically, building
up [INAUDIBLE].
So we can actually, rather than
just doing a giant string
concatenation, we could actually
just give an array of
all the different parts.
In this case, it's the
delimiters, content tapes, the
metadata for the file, which
is just a stringify JSON.
And then, our next section,
which is the file.
And one nice thing is that
when we do this, we can
actually mix content.
So we can mix text, and
we can mix binary.
So whereas in the QuickStart
example we were forced to do
base-64-encoding of the
content in order to be
compatible with how the
JavaScript client worked, in
this case, we could actually
just use the raw binary.
It saves us a little bit of
bandwidth in terms of how the
file is sent over the wire.
It's also a little bit less
processing, because we don't
have to do anything with
the content itself.
We can just assemble this part,
give it the raw binary,
along with the correct content
type, and send that.
Other than actually how the body
is formatted, the rest of
the code is the same as we did
with the media upload, which
is we do a post to the
upload endpoint.
The difference is we do
multipart instead of media.
We also change the content type
to indicate that this is
a multipart request.
Tell it the boundary.
And send the body.
And of course, the onComplete
and onError are just call
backs to let us know when
that request is done.
And that's where we're
updating the
UI to show the media.
There's a third upload protocol,
which is actually
really interesting,
and the preferred
way for doing uploads.
And it's called resumable
uploads.
Unfortunately, I didn't quite
get around to writing all the
code for it.
But I do promise that I will
clean up the examples that we
have in here today.
We'll add them to the GitHub
repository on Google Drive.
And we'll show you how to do all
three variants of uploads
in JavaScript.
And hopefully make the code
pretty reusable, so you can
just take that into your app and
use it yourself or adapt
it to your needs.
But you can get a little bit
of a flavor for it here in
some commented out code.
It's very similar to multipart
in that you supply both the
metadata for the file, as well
as the content itself.
It's just that you actually do
this across several requests.
So in the first request,
we do a post with
upload type as resumable.
But the content type, in this
case, is just the metadata.
It's just JSON with the body.
And we give it a couple of
little bits of extra
information via headers, just
to tell it about the content
that we're going to upload, what
its type is, and what the
expected file size is.
And that's via these
upload headers.
And once we do that, we're going
to get a redirect to
just a ephemeral URL, which
represents our upload session.
Again, this is the part that I
haven't quite gotten around to
implementing.
But then once we do that,
we can start to
upload the file in chunks.
The preferred approach, when
doing resumable uploads, is to
actually try and upload the
entire file at once and then
resume if the connection
fails.
In the case of a browser,
because there are limits on
how much memory you can have,
how much of a file you can
actually read into the browser
at one point in time, chunking
is actually a good
option here.
And so if you wanted to say, for
example, implement video
upload in your application to
Drive where you have a video
that could be several gigabytes
large that you might
be uploading from a desktop,
it's probably something that
you're going to want chunk
into smaller bits.
And you can do any size chunk.
The minimum is 256K.
But any multiple of
that is fine.
So you can do whatever
it is, two megabytes
at a time per chunk.
And then just incrementally
upload.
And the nice thing is if it
fails, or somebody's on their
laptop and they lose
their internet
connection, it's fine.
You actually have the course
of about 24 hours or so to
actually resume that upload.
And so that actually works
really nice for packaged apps.
You're on a Chromebook, and you
just happen to be going
around and maybe you're in
and out of connectivity.
But you can get that really,
really nice upload experience
into your app just using built
in browser features.
So again, I'll actually finish
this implementation hopefully
later today.
Get that up on GitHub for
everyone to take a look at.
And hopefully this is of use.
I know we've seen a lot of
interest on this in Stack
Overflow, a lot of questions
about how do you do upload in
JavaScript with CORS.
Great news is, starting today,
you can do that.
It's actually pretty
easy to do.
So that's all I really
have for CORS.
For next week, [INAUDIBLE]
is going to be in.
And she will be talking about
a recent sample that she
posted also on our
github.com/googledrive
repositories, which is a really
cool cross client
authentication and authorization
example that
shows how to do sign in on
mobile devices, and have that
identity and your authorization
propagate back
to your backend server, so you
can use APIs like Drive.
It's really a cool sample.
It's definitely a topic that
is a little tricky
to do and get right.
But again, she'll give
you a nice walk
through of how that works.
We'll be back with hopefully
a new app of the week.
And that's about it.
Again, if you have any
questions, come find us on the
Google Drive SDK developers
community or Stack
Overflow, of course.
We'd love to get
your feedback.
How you're using some of
these new features.
And of course, always want to
know what you're building.
So that's all for me today.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]